we have six applications to consider
along with the report on planning
appeals I'm happy with this and intend
to take the business in order set out on
the agenda
starting with item one apologies for
absence
uh yes chair we've received apologies
from councilor Rouse who's substituted
by councilor lazy apologies have also
been received from councilor Hancock
who's been substituted by councilor
winley and counselor our Hall
substituted by councilor funnel
apologies have also been received from
councilor Peter Elliott thank you chair
thank you we've not received any other
apologies none of us received here okay
item two Declarations of Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
pequenary interest and or other interest
not already on their register of
Interest
in any item on the agenda and can
withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
do members have any interest to declare
on receiver
thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on Tuesday the 21st of March of
this year are we happy that they are
correct record my wheelchair thank you
thank you all those in favor
uh here
apologies sure
I need to abstain because I wasn't here
that's fine thank you I think there's a
couple that weren't here as well yeah
three
the motion was carried thank you
we can move to the main business of this
afternoon
before we start I'd like the clerk to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on YouTube
we will deal with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and how copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask this be
any speakers to address the meeting
speakers will have three minutes to pour
forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points that
they have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting but they will not be allowed
to participate further from this point
the chair will then open up the meeting
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members as you know this meeting
is being live streamed and recording
will be made which will be placed on the
council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you we'll move to our first
application which is
ned421 forward slash zero one four nine
five forward slash FL at Homewood I'll
hand over to uh our planning officers
thank you chair
this application seeks consent to
redevelop the site for 41 dwellings it's
proposed that 22 of these will be Grant
funded delivered by registered housing
provider the site has previously been
granted planning permission for
development and this application seeks
to replicate that design and layout the
site is located in an area allocative
housing in the local plan and so the
principle of the site's development as
such is acceptable in planning policy
terms officers contend that the mix of
units is acceptable and there is no
unacceptable impact on neighboring
properties and also chair officers
consider there is no technical issue
that weighs against the proposal in
respect of social mitigation officers
consider the package of mitigation put
forward is acceptable in view of the
viability issue set out and tested by
the council by the applicant as such
share officers recommend the application
is approved and just a few slides to his
name Memoir from yesterday's site visit
chair members will recall the app
education site at Homewood it's outlined
in beige here the Chesterfield Road
running north south generally in this
location in the five pits Trail
west to east and then the Park Road
Industrial Area Beyond Chesterfield Road
to the east existing Residential
Properties on Chesterfield Road and
ongoing development on the west and
south of the site and the public
footpath referred to runs along the
south of the site here chair
the application site at light in red
with the other land owned by the
applicant in blue in this instance
and then share the layout as as we saw
yesterday for the the units
and then three convictive slides showing
the the units that are proposed
and finally chair just a
slide showing the the application site
with the properties on Chesterfield Road
in the background and that supplements
the other photographs that are in the
report that members will have share and
keep
thank you I believe we have one speaker
for this application Stephen Haslam
would you like to take the table
alternative this
if you'd like to state your name in
three minutes when you're ready
am I switched on now
excellent
thank you chair my name is Stephen
Haslam Mitchell Proctor architect
speaking in support of this application
as reported by your planning manager
this site and the development already
benefits from a live planning consent
granted previously for the 41 dwellings
in August 2021.
the site layout and house types have
essentially remained exactly the same
other than very minor amendments to suit
highways and drainage and the location
of the communal bin store
this application has been made to alter
a condition to allow for the affordable
housing element to be Grant funded the
previous permission restricted the
registered provider great places from
doing this
great places housing group is a
registered social landlord that owns and
manages 24 000 properties across the
North West Yorkshire and East Midlands
the organization has been working
closely with the applicant for some time
and is committed to providing 22
affordable homes on this scheme which
will be Grant funded through their homes
England strategic partnership program
great places have secured 240 million
pounds through the Strategic partnership
program to develop nearly 5 000
affordable homes across the north by
2028.
there is an ambitious development
pipeline to deliver a thousand
affordable homes a year over the next 10
years the District of Northeast
Derbyshire forms one of those
organizations key growth areas
the 22 Grant funded affordable homes
proposed as part of this development
equates to 54 of the scheme and will be
owned and managed by great places
with the properties being added to their
stock profile portfolio
a neighborhood service manager under the
supervision of an area service manager
will carry out the management role and
will deal with lettings and tenancy
management matters
this team is based at the regional
office in Sheffield
all 22 affordable homes will be led as
affordable rent and will comprise of the
following makes
ten two bed homes 10 3 bed homes and two
four bed homes
there is a recognized need for two three
and four bedroom homes for affordable
rent within this area
our first 30 seconds remaining on first
let all properties will be allocated via
nominations from Northeast Derbyshire
District Council through advertisement
on choice move and their choice based
letting scheme the remaining 9 19 homes
will be delivered for outright outright
sale
during the course of this application we
have worked closely with your planning
manager and former director to get this
application into a format which suits
all parties and practices to deliver
the Housing Development thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
please thank you if you'd like to take
your seat
are there any questions for our planning
offices
no wow
okay
so I can open the floor to debate should
there you need councilor Foster
thank you chair
um I notice in this case uh the 106
requests we've got 208 000 uh provision
and we've got requests of 460 uh from
DCC at 20 towards Health provision and
34 700 and a further just shot to be 11.
uh for off-site play provision
um
what's often what often ends up being
provided with applications like this we
find the money when it comes to DCC for
uh for the education and we find the
health one uh one area which we don't
end up finding money for because it's
all about who's pushing it is very often
um the off-site uh play provision so
that's a concern of mine the other will
get looked we'll get looked at and we'll
get pushed forward and it will be
fulfilled but if nobody at this point
looks after this part of it the play
provision this is something that doesn't
actually get done so it's not to not to
say that this is more important than
Education Health certainly not it's just
it's one that very often if we don't
push it forward it won't get done so I I
note uh and I know this is a part for
debate
and not apart for proposing
um anything at this point in the in the
application but when we look at Grant
permission subjects conditions and we're
leaving the delegated authority to the
planning manager uh for the 106
agreement what I'd like to see included
is that uh the one that we've requested
as a council
the 34 34 700 and the uh the the 11 000
is that that is definitely included
uh in conditions and that the rest of it
be down to the planning manager so that
they're my thoughts chair thank you
thank you I do agree we tend to see a
lot of provision going to County and we
seem to lose out I'd like to see again I
know we're not into uh proposal
if we do go ahead with this I would like
a definite proposition made for Parks
monies for Northeast because we do tend
to dip out on this and it's quite
important
any other comment
no thank you
if there's no other comments to be made
I'll open the floor for a motion
councilor Foster thank you chair
happy to propose uh along with uh what
he says on page 25 uh seven
recommendation Grant permission subjects
conditions all as we've said but include
uh the play provision for the amounts
quoted
on page 24
6.32 so I'd like to propose that chair
I'll secondary
thank you all those in favor
we have a role called I think it appears
by acclimation is that the case members
is all not all members just ask one
question please um in noting but um the
committee's view is
appears to be the rest of the money I
presume members would be happy for that
to be pro-rared amongst the other two
the other two request doors so have the
off-site play provision in full and then
the rest of the money dividely priority
between the the other two and that's
clear thank you
thank you we'll move to item two
energy forward slash 22 forward slash
zero one two one three
thank you
all slash FL upper town
thank you chair
firstly I'd like to refer members to the
late comments report of yesterday we've
had a number of emails from the
applicants agent which have been
replicated in full
um as far as they affect this
application in that update and brief
comments of officers to address them but
in terms of the updates report yeah that
does address and bring to members
attention all the applicants agents late
comments and officers chair apologize
for the issue about referencing your
other applications in the report which
officers a review that doesn't make the
committee prejudiced in determining the
application this afternoon so they don't
raise issues of planning merits that
would alter the the balance
in this case chair the applicant seeks
to construct a new house on the site and
in so doing remove all the other
buildings from it additionally two other
ancillary buildings would be constructed
to there referred to as the the barn and
the
um room that would assist with covering
the water supply in addition shares a
result of that activity the domestic
cartilage would also be extended as a
result of any permission that may be
granted and that's set out in the report
and plans and slides are referenced with
that
site lies an open Countryside sharing
within a primary area of multiple
environmental sensitivity which
comprises the best Landscapes within
Northeast Derbyshire offices contend the
resultant dwelling would fail to Accord
with your local and policy ss9 due to
its scale massing and layout
notwithstanding the comments made
otherwise officers also consider it
would adversely affect the important
landscape in which it would be located
and be especially so so in short
distance views from the local Highway
and public rights net right-of-way
Network
they don't appear to be any technical
reasons otherwise though to resist the
application accordingly chair officers
are recommending the application is
refused
just in terms of some Aid Memoirs to
yesterday's site visit again share memsa
recall has seen Cullum Lane as it winds
through the settlement of upper town
the application site lies to the south
south east of Columba Lane it's part of
a wider site that incorporates this
traditional land here chair I set out in
the in the paperwork
the applicant seeks to construct a new
dwelling which is this building here
a new Barn Building here chair and a
plant room to the to the north of the
site Columba Lane running here the new
public right of way that's proposed to
be
diverted from its current line would run
to the east of the site here rather than
through the existing site as shown in
the papers
this is the existing Farmhouse chair
that's left-hand side of this building
here and an Associated agricultural
building to the right hand side and the
new dwelling would sit and it's larger
but it would sit roughly in this area of
the site
that's the dwelling Rich proposed chair
and that's the layout of the building
the room layout
that chair comprises the building that
would be the barn and referred to in the
papers
and that is the plant room
and just to remind members chair that
that is the the building that was
discussion yesterday this portion of the
building is the existing Farmhouse and
this is building attached to it that was
previously used or last used for
agricultural purposes
and just looking into the site from the
highway Network which Ellis is taken
from culin Bell Lane the application
site to the right here and just shows
the the foot path currently runs through
the buildings
and then finally chaired that's from a
slide taken from Columbia Lane itself
back towards the existing arm house
I think that's all chair thank you
thank you we have two speakers for this
item an agent and a supporter with
William Marshall is the agent
if you'd like to confirm your name in
three minutes when you're ready
thank you Joe yeah good afternoon all my
name is William Marshall I'm the agent
for this application and we'll be
speaking on behalf of the applicant this
is the first of two applications that my
client has been determined at this
committee today which is the culmination
of three years of work to transform a
dilapidated site into my client's dream
home for that family
after me you'll be hearing from Rose
Walker who will speak about landscape
character and so in order to avoid
repetition I'll be speaking solely about
the planning merits of the application
firstly I may welcome the clarifications
made in the late representations
document which confirmed the red line
boundary and the fact that the proposed
development will not impact on the
footpath running through the sides
however we believe there is still a
fundamental misunderstanding of part one
F policy ss9 to clarify matters part 1 F
States in full and I quote the change of
use reuse limited infilling or
Redevelopment of vacant derelict or
previously developed land which would
not have a greater impact on the
character of the countryside than the
existing development end quote meaning
that for part one F to apply the site
needs to be vacant or derelict or
previously developed land just one not
all three
given that the site in its existing form
is both vacant as The Farmhouse is
currently unused and derelict as the
barns have fallen apart the requirement
for the whole site to be previously
developed land does therefore not apply
and part one f is engaged
this allows for a larger dwelling
amendments to residential cartilage and
the change of use from agricultural to
residential and given this policy
allowance the question that remains is
whether the proposed development will
have a greater impact on the character
of the countryside than the existing Roz
will talk about this next but it's clear
that the existing site is a collection
of dilapidated buildings and that the
type of buildings Uptown are large and
varied the society the size of the
proposed replacement dwell in what's
bigger than the existing will therefore
not be excessive when compared to what
already exists nearby regarding design
it is acknowledged that the proposed
dwelling is more modern than existing
however this is a subjective matter
design cues have been taken from
traditional linear house at farm houses
and cable lens such as those immediately
to the North and the applicant is
committed to using natural stone but
there is some Modern glazing to make the
most of the View South and to create an
architectural feature
modern designs are not unusual
an example of this being slack Farm
nearby and whilst it is knowledge that
every planning case must be determined
on its own merits there must also be be
a degree of consistency in decision
making and therefore if slack Farm can
be approved then the applicant's
replacement violin which follows similar
principles should also be acceptable
we proposed replacement dwelling is
therefore no larger than the existence
and whilst it has modern elements is no
different to other approved schemes in
the district
I also want to remind members that this
application has no objections from
members of the public and four letters
in support somewhat of a rarity in rural
locations it is therefore respectfully
requested that the application is
approved thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions
I just have one for clarification I know
the building isn't being lived in but
are there people living on the site uh
yes my client is currently living into
Caravans on sites thank you
so no further questions we'll move to
the next speaker which is Rose Walker
if you'd like to confirm your name in
three minutes when you're ready thank
you chair
um hello all my name is Rose Walker I'm
a chartered landscape architect
for this application and for the
following application that we'll be
discussing in a minute I've undertaken
the landscape and visual impact
appraisal or lvia which looks at the
anticipated impacts on landscape
character and visual immunity
I've been a landscape architect
specializing in lva for 10 years and
have been charted since 2015. I wrote
the landscape team at Britain and green
environmental consultants and the lva
written for these applications has been
peer reviewed by one of my colleagues
looking at the proposed Farmhouse
development the main landscape character
affects the replacement will be on the
side a substantial adverse impact is
appraised during construction as
construction activities in Congress in
the rural site although the effects are
both temporary and reversible this level
of effect is typical for construction
activity within a rural context
by year one and year 15 of operation the
effect of the landscape character the
site would reduce to minor beneficial
this is because the proposed development
would improve the landscape condition
and Scenic quality of the site by
removing the dilapidated and derelict
existing buildings and rationalizing the
number of these to three buildings
whilst the height of the proposed
dwelling is taller than the existing the
footprint is comparable to the existing
buildings in this part of the site the
Heights and Footprints of the other two
proposed buildings are also comparable
to existing buildings
the proposed development will provide an
aesthetic for a primary dwelling in a
hard standing yard with two smaller
subsidiary outbuildings this is similar
in character to a farmyard and Echoes
the Baseline character of the side
the post material for new buildings is
Stone which is incube with both The
Farmhouse building to be replaced as
well as other buildings within the local
area
in addition to the proposed running
users architectural Design Elements
which reference the historic buildings
within upper town such as the chimneys
on each end of the roof and The Gables
above the windows in the Southeastern
elevation these architectural elements
are already referenced in nearby local
buildings such as those in the opposite
side of Columbia Lane
for The Wider landscape the effects in
The Proposal elements are reduced in
comparison to those on the site these
effects reduced to neutral during year
one of operation because the proposed
development Echoes some of the key
characteristics of the landscape
character types within the surrounding
landscape so it echoes the dispersed
sandstone farmsteads and the clusters of
farmsters and Cottages which are
recorded in the wooded slopes and
valleys LCT
the lvaa shows that care views have
proposed from the sorry the key is the
police development from the property
rights of way on the southern
Northeastern site boundaries as well as
the highway adjacent by year one of
operation the existing unsightly and
derelict buildings within the site were
removed from the Middle Ground of these
views they would be replaced by 30
buildings which reference local
materials and Architectural features in
turn this would improve the views and
give a minor beneficial effect the use
from further afield would experience
reduced effects due to intervening
vegetation
I hope this is provided an overview of
the Landscaping which aspects related to
the proposed relevant and help to
further clarify the reasoning behind my
professional opinion that the proposed
development is beneficial in landscape
and visual terms following construction
please let me know if you have any
questions and thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions
no thank you if you'd like to take a
seat
are there any questions for our officers
Council Armitage
thank you uh you know you stated that
the
development is outside the settlement
development we manage
right where does the settlement
development limit run
there isn't one that's defined for upper
town in your local plan chair so there
isn't one that's right okay and how much
bigger is this development
uh than the existing building which is
already the percentage-wise
not to undertaken an assessment of the
percentage share but I've got some
measurements here
astrology would like me to just give
them to you
he
existing Farmhouse so it's the existing
Farmhouse rather than the
agricultural building next door to which
is slightly taller so the existing Farm
out is 5.9 meters to Apex of roof and
the new dwelling is proposed at 8.8
meters to roof the existing Farmhouse
building is 12.7 meters long by 4.7
meters deep again that's not including
the agricultural building next door to
it and the hose dwelling is 22.5 meters
long and eight meters deep
so the the um
new dwelling would sit
roughly won't be larger than the on the
where the existing dwelling is plus the
agriculture building next door to it
so you've included the agricultural
building next door in their measurements
now just so I can be clear chat um the
existing dwelling house that's on the
site is 12.7 meters long whereas the
proposed dwelling house is 22.5 meters
long
but I'm
trying to explain that the proposed
dwelling is on the rough footprint of
the existing dwelling plus that
agricultural building that sits next
door to it
so it will basically replace two uh
semidarily buildings
because
uh I know the building I've seen it
there for eight or nine years and it's
slowly gone down and down and it would
basically replace one I saw within the
with something which will far more
appealing
well the Judgment that you will have to
make is the impact of the new
development on the character of the area
and the in the countryside so that's the
Judgment you'll have to make
the issue that the application is made
to construct three new buildings in
effect a new dwelling a new barn come
garage and the plant room and all the
other buildings on that site would be
removed so that that's the
um equation I guess that you need to to
consider as your what does the
application propose so if you were of
the view that the removal of those other
buildings was
material to your consideration and all
the other matters fell away or weren't
of import then that would be ultimately
what you're considering but your policy
requires you to go one step further than
that and consider the impact on of the
buildings on the character of the
countryside
are there any questions for the officers
no I'll open the floor for debate should
there beaver
Council Armitage
thank you chair well
I've looked at this and I can remember
this building both the buildings uh well
all of the buildings let's face it are a
bit of an ISO in the village
uh We've looked at uh the land the
effect on the landscape and quite
frankly I think it won't make much
difference they're all different
buildings in upper town if you go around
there are none the same and this would
be just as far as I'm concerned it
wouldn't be a problem with it if we look
at ss9 uh 0.8 uh
going to f it says that uh on change of
you so reuse limited info and
Redevelopment of vacant derelict or
previously developed land and I think
that this fits that criteria quite
easily
and what's going to happen if we turn it
down I can't see you know it'll just
get more and more derelict and it'll end
up being an isil where this gentleman is
obviously going to do a lot to it and
build it up and every building that is
put in for uh it's going to replace
something which is either is going to
fall down and what's the best thing
that's right regards the landscape a
heap of rubble or a new house
any other comment
no oh counselor we've got to do now
ladies first
um no I'm just going to agree with
William actually because looking at
these pictures it is in a dreadful State
and there's a tree growing out of
out of a building
um
yeah
I must have met yesterday when I looked
at the plans I thought oh dear that
looks a little bit larger and not in
keeping well actually when you look when
you look at this the overall size and
impact
it's better than what's there
outside
I'm another one who's in agreement with
William on this one to be honest I think
yeah the proposal gives us a much better
building than what's already there and
provide somebody with a nice absolutely
in a nice area
thank you
that's the end of the boat I'll ask for
a motion to be put forward
counter Armitage yeah I uh go against
officer's recommendation and we look at
policy
ss9f uh which uh involves the ReUse
of a development which is already there
it's got uh all of the I think most of
the houses in upper town uh are on
spring water and they do have to have a
building in which to house everything so
that is a you know it's a function
that's definitely needed and I think as
regards the landscape uh
uh um uh sdc3 I think it's a you know
it's a non-starter really because it's
going to improve the landscape no end of
this
have our second counselor Lucas
foreign
just to ask members if they are I need
to Grant permission for the scheme
whether they would delegate conditions
to myself in consultation with yourself
and the vice chair chair or whether you
have
um suggested conditions that you would
want to attaching to any permission so
that's the query chair
I think we'll leave it to you Andrew
that would be in consultation with
yourself and the vice chair
so we're going to have a vote uh just to
be clear on that then so it's to reject
officer recommendations and to approve
the application essentially because it
would be in line with policy ss9 with
the final conditions delegated to the
planning manager development manager in
consultation with you and the vice chair
is that the essence of it
so would you like me to now carry out a
roll culture yes please
counselor Armitage
councilor Cooper
councilor Foster
councilor for now
councilor harzone
or
councilor Lacey oh
councilor Liggett for
councilor Jones oh
councilor Powell
councilor roof against
and councilor winley oh
make it seven for the motion and four
against Southern motion as pasture
thank you
we can move on to the next application
which is same development different
number 22 4 0 1 2 7 2 4 FL
thank you chair first of all again I
refer members to the late comments
report of yesterday
again addresses the issues raised by the
applicants agent chair and officers
apologize again for any rev ever in
referencing applications in the report
but again this isn't considered
prejudicial to the determination of the
application by the committee
in this case chair the applicants seek
consent to remove an agricultural
building and replace it with another the
site lies in open Countryside and within
a primary area of multiple environmental
sensitivity comprising the best
Landscapes within Northeast Derbyshire
the existing building has a limited
height overall whereas that now proposes
is an officer's opinion more bulky and
so more impactful on the area being
readily apparent in localized views even
if it is largely softened in longer
views of the site
officers acknowledge there is no
requirement to submit the internal
layout of buildings but without that and
details of the farming activities taking
place on the site officers are unable to
assess how the building may serve the
farming Enterprise of a unit
adding to officer concerns is lack of
information regarding levels and so how
the building May sit on the land in its
finished form notwithstanding that chair
there appear no technical reasons to
resist the application but officers in
this case share recommend the
application is refused and just to take
you through some slides as an aid Memoir
to to yesterday again the application
site in beige here the the application
that you've just considered lies to the
Southwest columbell Lane coming through
upper town
and in this case share the application
site outlined in red and the applicant
seek consent to demolish a range of
agricultural buildings primarily single
story but with a two-story and higher
central element and as part of that
Redevelopment line of right-of-way would
run through part of a single story
element of that and it would result in
leaving single building
um on the site there is a track already
formed across the land that runs in this
direction it is proposed that that's
modified to run towards the building but
the applicant is Keen for members to be
aware that planning consent isn't sought
for that and it would rely on permitted
development rights which do allow for
the formation of tracks on Holdings of
this size but in all cases the track
would then need to be reasonably
necessary for agricultural purposes but
that is not an issue that the applicant
wishes to be considered this afternoon
Jen he is going to rely on
agriculturated rights
it's in terms of the building itself Jay
you can see top left the
floor layout of the existing building
so that's in in red the central spine of
it this area here is to story with the
remainder being single story and you can
see the design of the building on the
the right hand side and the bottom of
the slide this is the elevation that
would face Southeast and this is the
elevation that would face onto the the
new track that is proposed to be formed
and the other two elevations you can see
um referenced at top right and bottom
left
so just in terms of pictorial form again
with the caveat that as we discussed
yesterday that the site isn't flat
although the drawings do show it as a
flat site the existing building outline
is in red
so you can see the
mainly single story element with the
central spine being two story in height
and then from the elevation that you
would see from the road
and finally share just a couple of
photographs of the building itself this
is the existing building on the site
single story elements wrapping around
the building with the central two-story
spine that I've referred to and then
looking from Columbia Lane itself to the
site and hopefully this exemplifies the
issue about levels which I was
discussing earlier but a single story
element of the building either side with
the two-story spine in the middle I
think that's well
um just for say completeness chair this
is the the track that's referred to
that's been formed as I say the
applicant is intending to realign the
track to access the new elevation of the
building that were faced towards Cullen
Bell Lane and we're assured that the
rest of the track will be reinstated to
field but again just to make it clear
chair the applicant isn't seeking
planning consent for that track and he
would intend to rely on permitted rights
to form it I think that's all chat thank
you thank you
we have the same two speakers again
um
Mr Marshall
three minutes when you're ready
again
um as previously discussed I'm the agent
I'll be speaking on behalf of the
applicant
um so this plan application relates to
the provision of a replacement Barn to
the east of the name Uptown Farmhouse
that you determine prior to this
uh once again my colleague Rose will
speak about landscape character
um again it is noted that within the
late representations document the
officer clarifies that planning
permission is not sort of the access
track and this is welcomed and should
not part form part of any planning
balance
uh moving to the planning merits of the
case as confirmed in paragraph 6.6 of
the planet officers report the proposed
replacement ban would occupy a lesser
footprint and a lesser volume than the
existing Barn
the proposals are therefore compliant
with part 1A of policy ss9 of the local
plan which allows for a replacement
building for the same use and is not
significantly larger than the building
it replaces
this aspect is therefore quite clear
however part two of ss9 also requires
all development to respect the form
scale and character of the landscape
through careful sighting scale design
and use of materials
at Ms walk or discuss landscape Clarity
in more detail but it's clear the
existing Barn is a mismatch of metal
cladding concrete blocks and Old Timber
supports there is no planning policy
requirement to demonstrate how an
agricultural building is or will be used
but it is clear that the existing Barn
is not fit for purpose for modern
agriculture
as a result the replacement barn with
simple dimensions and a flexible
footprint has been submitted however the
officer's report concludes that the
design of the replacement bond is more
akin to an industrial building than
something that is agricultural
we strongly disagree with this
assessment and have provided examples of
approved bonds within uh submitted
planning statement that share similar
materials and design to what we are
proposing
in terms of scale and massing numerous
Bonds in the area can be considered
comparative including to the north of
the site in upper town itself a recently
completed barn on Alice Head Road to the
Northeast and on Hodge Lane to the West
given that all these are larger than our
proposed Barn we struggle to see why is
an unacceptable design
in our view it is therefore clear that
the proposed replacement bomb will not
see an increase in volume and footprint
and will match the materials and massing
of neighboring Barns and those recently
approved we therefore respectfully
request to the planning application is
approved and the replacement Bond
allowed thank you
thank you are there any questions
Council of Cooper and councilor pal
thank you chair
what is the existing building currently
used for please
um so it's used for an Agricultural
purpose the my client has a small
holding so it's currently used for
storage they did have chickens but then
there was the avian flu so that's not
currently being used for chickens but
their plan is to get chickens again
councilor pal uh similar question really
Mr Marshall
um bearing in mind the whole site
this is not as big as a farm and is is
is
um it's a much smaller what's
agricultural activity is currently
taking place or is proposed
yeah so the the barn actually or my
client owns the field that the barn is
in and also the field to the south of
The Farmhouse
um if you can remember that on on the
plan
um so at the moment as I say they used
to have chickens they've also had goats
in the past they've also done
um like hay crop as well and so the barn
at the moment is currently just used for
the storage of that but it is I believe
the timber supports Insider old
Telegraph polls so it's it's not
currently fit for purpose so this is to
kind of consolidate everything that's
there and build something that that is
that was built essentially
so you wouldn't consider it's a large
bomb for a small site
no as I say it's it's it's an adjacent
field as well I appreciate that it's not
the biggest farm in the world but it's a
replacement building footprint's the
same uh smaller and the volume is the
same
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
oh councilor Armitage thank you uh the
site is uh it has an agricultural uh uh
number I take it
yes my client has a small hold in County
Parish holding number yeah yeah so it
has an agricultural holding number yes
right and the other thing is how many
acres are the total of grassland uh I'm
not entirely sure to be honest
um I'm not look at my client I'm not
sure if she knows
around five five acres thank you
any other questions
thank you if you'd like to take a seat
you're up again Miss Walker
thank you again chair
as mentioned for the previous
application I have also undertaken the
lva for the proposed Bond development in
parallel with the proposed development
dwelling application
as before my work looks at the
anticipated impacts on landscape
character and visual immunity and it has
been peer reviewed by my colleague from
within the landscape team at Brendan
green
the largest landscape character effects
of the proposed Bond development would
be those on the site construction
activity would be in Congress within the
site given the lack of existing
construction or similar activity within
it therefore the effects of construction
on its landscape character would be
substantial adverse again I hastened to
add that this is typical through
construction of a development within a
rural environment and it is worth noting
that the effects during construction
would be short-term reversible and
temporary
the effect on the landscape touch of the
site in years 1 and 15 of operation
would reduce to minor beneficial the
existing bomb within the site is in poor
condition which adversely affects the
perceived landscape quality and Scenic
quality within the Baseline side
the replacement with a post barn would
remove the dilapidated and unattractive
existing barn and in turn improve the
scenic quality and Landscape condition
of the site
looking in turn at the massing of the
proposed development in comparison to
the existing building and in comparison
to local vernaculars
excuse me the footprint with the
proposed on is smaller than that
existing and the overall Ridge height is
comparable the overall proposed arm will
appear more as a single structure than
the existing building which comprises a
two-story core with single story wings
at either side whilst the single block
structure would appear as a larger Mass
its smaller footprint would reduce the
lateral extent of built form within the
site thus from a landscape point of view
I consider these two elements to balance
in addition there are already other
barns present in the local vicinity with
a greater footprint in massing such as a
plum tree farm on the opposite side of
columbell Lane
in terms of appearance the proposed
shooting and blockwork materials palette
Echoes that for the bonds found locally
and is typical of an agricultural Barn
similar bonds are found within the wider
landscape and Echo the rural
agricultural character and the dispersed
farmstead's characteristic that is
recorded in the published landscape
character assessment for the wooded
slopes of Alice LCT
as well as the sparsely scattered
isolated farmsteads recorded in both the
enclosed Moors and Heath LCT and the
enclosed grit Stone Uplands LCT
given that the proposed development
Echoes this wider character the effects
on the wider landscape character in
these lcts during years 1 and 15 of
operation is neutral
the public rights of way on the Southern
and norfolks inside boundary and the
highway on cullenborough Lane are the
key locations from which the proposed
with farm development will be viewed for
these views the changes within them
would again occur within the Middle
Ground by year one of operation the
removal of the unattractive existing
bond from The View and replacement with
the proposed development will give a
minor beneficial effect due to which
retractor being removed from the
Viewpoint intervening vegetation with
limits views from further afield
hopefully this has helped to explain
some of the reason we provide the
professional judgments I've recorded in
the lva answer any questions
thank you are there any questions
no thank you very much thank you chair
are there any questions for the officers
Council apparel
I'm going to clarificationally on the
previous application
we approved a house small building for
the water element and and the building
described as a bomb
um
so there's already a barn there
from the previous application do they
need in it why would they need another
barn in your view
I don't know why I can't ask you why
they would need another Don that's up to
you to say that but just for
clarification about what we've approved
and what we're being asked to improve
just on the the previous application
chair the
long thin building to the south east of
the new dwelling house was described in
the application as a barn although from
my
eye it looked more like a an extended
three-doored garage but it was described
as a barn in terms of the the current
application you've heard what's been
said this afternoon and you've read the
officer report officers did seek further
clarification in terms of the
Agricultural activity on the site and
also any more information as to how the
the building would be used particularly
in view of its its design the window
openings and the large roller shutter
door that would face actually a wave
from
the track that would access it which
would be faced by the single Personnel
Bill we were sent some photographs as Mr
Marshall says which I can't validate but
they did show
um goats and chickens and a field being
mode available I can't say where that
was we did seek that extra clarification
to try and inform Our advice to you this
afternoon chair but we didn't receive
anything so as Pastor Armitage discussed
with Mr Marshall there is a holding
number
um agricultural holding number on the
the unit but the two sites as far as the
information that I have
combined both the the one that will now
be built on of the house and the the
barn and the plant room and this
application site the housing application
site is described as 0.932 hectares and
this site is 0.35 hectares I believe
that comes out at roughly 3.23.3 Acres
so I can't comment on future use of the
building but I do hope some of that that
background to our officers have come to
our conclusion helps chair
thank you are there any other questions
councilor Cooper
thank you chair
um
Adrian this this Barn doesn't look much
like a barn to me as outlined in in the
report is there anything that would be
acceptable to
notwithstanding the issue about the the
site size and how the land would be used
you would expect agricultural buildings
to be located in this environment but
you would expect them to be constructed
to to meet a certain requirement so it
would have been helpful in this case to
understand perhaps what Machinery was
used for the land and what the use of
the land was to to be for whether it was
for sheep or or other livestock or just
for for storing hay but but certainly in
terms of the design of it particularly
in terms of the window openings and the
Personnel door at the one end
and that's not what I would normally
expect to see um from an agricultural
building that's that's used for those
purposes long term you will expect some
openings often agriculture buildings are
open-sided particularly where they've
got livestock being added to them so in
answer your question accounts Cooper
there would if the site is is generally
news factors you would expect some
buildings to serve that it's just in
this instance because of the the
character of the building and its its
design officers to have concerns about
its impact on the the character of the
area particularly in the in the local
views from the public footpath network
which runs very close to the site
whether it's diverted form or its
current form and the highway Network
so any further questions
if not I'll open the floor for debate
answer Armature
yeah uh
I'd like just to uh make members aware
that uh
I am qualified uh as a father and I can
speak on this
in that area
well now the whole of the ashova ward
has been played by theft of agricultural
machinery
and this building well the existing
building couldn't hold anything
uh we've been asked about uh it's a it's
actually a smaller footprint
it's in keeping with the area as regards
uh
what's proposed and if we're talking
about hey well Hayes got to be stacked
up
and the way they stuck it up these days
are using half ton and tumbails on the
lifted up and stacked up as high as they
can go
and for security reasons this building
uh has to it's the only way you can
secure things from being uh stolen we've
had in the area uh there was a la shift
uh
a mobile Handler stolen we've had
tractor stolen you name it now sarama
did you be going off the point here no
we're not yes you are no I disagree with
you because
Adrian has said there is no use for
agriculture that's not what he said is
the design of the building I think we
need to move on cancer well the design
of the building is such for security
reasons for storing stuff securely so
it's not stolen
any other comment
no I'll open the floor for a motion
it is
I appreciate that chair uh I've got very
similar concerns to I believe what
albash chairs put forward and the
consent of the officers
um
I I won't skirt around it I've got
concerns uh when we look at 6.8
paragraph page 54.
when we speak about domestic style
Windows how it's been designed uh put on
agricult agricultural use
um
we're seeing more and more
buildings being put up in Northeast
Derbyshire and was seen him uh as a
committer here where people are asking
to put build buildings up for
agricultural purposes and then three
four years later five years later
they're coming back for conversion and
we've seen a lot of them we've seen one
recently in dronfield and we've seen one
recently in the green belt uh in killer
Marsh and all and we discussed that one
in killer Marsh at the length here same
number of openings the openings aren't
going to change doors in the same place
windows in the same place and then later
on in the same ground somebody wants a
barn further down in the same I think
Council Lacey over there knows which one
I'm talking about you've been involved
in it and we're getting more and more of
this now
if we look at the possible future use
which our officers can't comment on and
rightly so it's not a material
consideration completely got that and
neither are the past applications when
we look at the past applications they've
been for uh two of them being for
dwellings
uh dwelling houses so all the signs are
there now if we're happy to do this as a
planning Authority and encourage more of
this this is the way to go but we must
do it with with our eyes open
all the all the signs are there and we
just got to be honest yes we're happy
for people to build agricultural
buildings and then possibly let's
convert them we just got to be square so
people that come along know that we're
that we're happy to do that or here
while we can't use uh possible future
use and pest applications as material
considerations our offices have given us
plenty
um policies to look at ss1 ss9 sdc3 12
uh of the local plan and uh three
policies and they actually have a
neighborhood plan so there's plenty
there for us and it's those policies we
should be discussing
not that it currently looks like an
eyesore and somebody must do something
about it and it's going to look much
better it's the actual policies that are
important so we've got to look what's
actually going on in Northeast
Derbyshire and we got to decide as the
planning Authority which we which way we
do want to go uh like I said we can't
consider those things that mentioned as
planning considerations but that's
what's actually happening aside from
that we've got policy that actually
contains this sort of development
thank you chair
thank you I have to agree with
everything you've just said
are there any other comments to be made
no quite happy to move it to a roll call
vote and um the flight will go through
the motion it's pretty sure have we
actually got a motion then
I'm happy to put forward that we uh go
with officers recommendations
thank you
so the motion is
and that is to refuse planning
permission you're right Joe
uh right
um councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
Foster
councilor for now
councilor hartzon
against
councilor Lacey
for
counselor leggers oh
counselor Jones for
councilor Powell
councilor roof who
and councilor windley
oh
that's nine four and two against the
motion uh to approve officer
recommendations and reject the
application as a pasture thank you
thank you
we can move on to the next application
which is at Milltown Ned four slash 22
forward slash zero one zero seven seven
four slash FOH
Adventure chat firstly once again I
prefer members the late comments report
of yesterday in in this instance chair
unfortunately um due to a variety of
reasons the property name does appear as
two separate names throughout the report
part of that is
um as a result of the the application
form I'm afraid but um again it's not
considered by officers that that is
prejudicial to the termination of the
applications this afternoon chair there
are two applications that are identical
in form that members have next on the
agenda I'm doing I intend doing one
introduction share and one presentation
if that's acceptable to you but you will
need to take two votes over the two
applications because there may be
different considerations in respect of
the two of them thank you just in terms
of the first application chair that
seeks straightforward planning
permission for a single story extension
with the second seeking listed building
consent for that extension just to
confirm share the property is a listed
building and therefore as members will
be aware special considerations apply to
it and development that affects it
site lies in open Countryside and within
the primary area of multiple
environmental sensitivity comprising the
best Landscapes within Northeast
Derbyshire
in the countryside chair members are
aware that new development is strictly
controlled and irrespective dwellings
outside of settlements policy requires
that extensions which either
cumulatively or individually involve a
significant change to the scale and
character of the original dwelling
should be
um particularly assessed and in many
cases restricted
and as I say chair this supports the
general restricted policies in respect
of developing Countryside areas
in this case chair due to the scale of
extensions added to the dwelling both
previously and in this instance and the
visibility of the site offices officers
contend that the extension would result
in such a change and so it's
unacceptable
members will note the previous
applications determined on the site
share and I've got a slide that we saw
yesterday and I'll reprise that again
this afternoon and the extension at this
location that's now before you for
consideration this afternoon coupled
with one that was subsequently approved
was previously refused in the planning
history chair if because of the adverse
effect that the two extensions
cumulatively would have on the dwelling
in terms of its Heritage value
officers retain that view chair and that
the extension now proposed wood in
addition to that in the course of
construction impact adversely on the
overall Heritage value of the building
there are chair and officers opinion no
identified public benefits that outweigh
that conclusion
and additionally share both applications
are recommended for refusal
just in terms of the application sites
as we saw yesterday application site
called it in Beijing sits within the
Milltown fall gate area
orgate Quarry primary area down to the
Southwest jetting Street ear chair and
the highway Network along the Amber
Valley here and then up towards Milltown
and sorry foregate proper recent
development within the former Quarry
down to the the south of the site
the application site share outlined in
red the extension is to the Eastern
elevation of the building previously
extensions have been permitted to the
northern elevation and as I've said to
the Western elevation
so in terms of this application share
the application seeks consent for this
extension on the side of the property
and there would be an opening form to it
and so in detail this is the existing
front albeit with an extension permitted
in this area here and I'll show you a
slide of that in a second and this
application and these applications now
receive consent for this to the Western
oh sorry the Eastern elevation
this is
the extension that's proposed chair here
and then that's the the rear elevation
as is you can see the extension
previously consented which is this area
here the application extension is this
one here
just in terms of the the planning
history chair as I've just mentioned
there was an application previously
refused for extensions to both the
Western and Eastern elevations the
subsequent application just for this
addition to the Western elevation was
approved and it's in the course of
construction as we saw on the site visit
virtual site visit yesterday's this
extension is being constructed
this is the the front of the the
building and you can just see the
outline of the extension and the
excavations associated with it that's
under development
and just spinning ground share this is
also the front of the building the
extension would be on this elevation
here
so this this area here chair would see
the extension
thank you
thank you I do believe we've got two
speakers for this one
on the military
this is Simon Walkley
thank you
if you'd like to confirm your name in
three minutes when you're ready
yes Joe um my name is Simon workley and
I'm the applicant for Planning
Commission Minister building consent for
this property by way of background I've
lived at common Bank house for almost 13
years with my wife Janine and our two
children Olivia and William uh prior to
that I was brought up in Chesterfield
we're with tuition because we wanted the
children to grow up where there was more
space outside for them to play and where
there was a safeguard and both children
went for local primary school and we
feel we're part of the community with
lots of local friends we use a local
shop Butcher and post office all I am
told by Anna in the little shop that'll
be a few hundred years before we're
considered to be locals
we're falling in love with the house as
soon as we saw it and to be in derelict
for many years before renovation in 2005
but much of this was poorly done
the house is small and the children are
grown so the house seems to get smaller
we are in fact now four adults living
together we could move but we love where
we live we would never do anything that
we feel would be detrimental to the
property but things are not perfect it
needs a larger kitchen there's ongoing
movement to the Gable which you want to
stabilize and we have recurrent cracks
appearing along stress points in the
kitchen we can hear move into the wall
and there's often a gritty substance
found on the floor near what used to be
the fireplace in the morning there can
be a gritty film on top of our dog's
water bowl
I previously applied to extend the
kitchen but this was rejected but I took
note of Mr kirkham's comments but I did
not have a structural engineers report
I'd include the one with this
application a small kitchen extension
will act as a buttress to the Gable it
has been suggested that Standalone
buttresses could be built but I believe
these will be uncycling not at all in
keeping with the cottage they'll detract
from its beauty and character and not
preserve it if not sort of the
structural engine engineer believes the
whole Gable will in time need to be
rebuilt and then we lose all of what we
now seek to preserve
nutrition itself is not the purpose for
a family by way of example if the oven
door is open it can only have things
placed in it from the side there's not
enough space for us to stand in front of
the oven
it's not possible for tours to be in the
kitchen and to prepare a meal together
for instance nobody can stand at the
sink uh whilst the oven doors opened
we need a larger oven my son was
diagnosed with an eating disorder and
despite treatments this will always be
the case he can't eat the same meals as
us and we need to prepare separate meals
for the size of the oven which the
kitchen allows for means this can rarely
be ready at the same time for us to eat
together
the boilers in the kitchen underneath
underneath my daughter's bedroom it's
noisy and it wakes her in the night and
in the morning we would plan to place
the boiler in the kitchen extension
even during a bright summer's day we
need to have the lights on in the
kitchen due to the lack of natural light
this is not an exaggeration whilst we
don't propose a large window in the
extension having more will mean there's
more natural light we can use the room
without having to use electricity all of
the time 30 seconds remain yeah neither
the conservation office or the planning
office review the inside of my kitchen
so I do find it hard to understand how
they've assessed the proposals I do have
comments on the history of the building
but we'll talk about these under the
list of building consent thank you
here are there any questions counselor
Foster
uh yeah thank you chair uh
thank you Mr Wortley for that my
question is you mentioned around uh
should be gonna
yeah
you mentioned about you mentioned about
where your house is is situated and it's
covered in the in the in in the report
uh I've visited your property along with
the the local counselor
um Council Armitage and it's all about
are we your house six it's mentioned
that it's that it's on a hill uh but
I've looked for where it's visible and I
can't see that it's visible from
anywhere at all apart from a small gap
between two trees uh and that's it like
a road 200 meters away can you elaborate
any more on that please that's what I've
seen so it's about the visibility so
give other people apps in your property
an audio how it sits yes but that's part
of the reason the uh extension has been
designed as it says so from the I call
it the front of the house so um that's
the the very attractive bit with the um
with the lovely Stone windows so if you
were looking towards the front of the
house
um and you'd have to be quite some
distance well beyond the miner's arm so
I'd probably say at least a quarter of a
mile away before you can actually see
the front of the house and the extension
wouldn't be visible well then from the
front
um there's any other one house near
um near us actually sits just above us
that's common Bank Cottage it's not
possible to view the extension from
common Bank Cottage
um so yes you're right because of the
actual elevation although we're high up
actually the way the land Falls away it
means that from uh you'd have to be some
distance away to be able to actually see
the the extension for the extension
we've built in the same material as the
actual original wall so I think the
distance should have to be to be able to
see it I don't think you'd actually
noticed the difference
thanks for Beyonce I think that we're
pointing out chair yes thank you I do
know your property I've been passed have
a look as well and I agree you can't see
it I nearly got lost thank you
are there any other questions for the
speaker
councilor pal
um yeah I'm already thinking the
extension would go what is it what
effectively looks across a track or
drive
do you mean the actual
um the weather stones are or the side of
the current gay lens yeah that's just
our land there's no track or drive it's
just the way we would walk from the
where the cars parked to go into the
back Garden
and would they if the extension was
built would you still have access or
would you have to create another access
for walking or whatever no we've ensured
it's at least a meter wide so that um if
their wheelchair need to get by uh
they're still sufficient room for
wheelchairs lawn mowers whatever it
might be to uh to to still get by the
property as we could now thank you thank
you
are there any other questions no thank
you very much
our next speaker on this is Charlotte
spanker
three minutes when you're ready
Charlotte
thank you Charlotte stains and speaking
on behalf of the architect
some of you may remember that Simon and
I were here in 2019 in relation to
Simon's previous application for a
kitchen extension and sunroom
at that meeting the scheme was refused
by only one vote and Simon was
specifically told that he should have
provided a report from a structural
engineer to explain the issues with the
Gable
the design has been amended by a
different architect since the previous
scheme a structural report has now been
provided and the application is
accompanied by a design and Heritage
statement
we are surprised that the officer
reports do not refer to the previous
reason for refusal and this new
information to consider whether the
issues have now been overcome
my client's property is called common
Bank house there is significant
confusion about this in the report and
the recommendation itself refers to
Common Bank Cottage which is next door
we are concerned that the proposals have
not been considered thoroughly Simon has
confirmed that no internal inspection of
the kitchen the proposed location of the
opening or the Gable wall has taken
place
the officer report confirms in section 7
that the principle of an extension can
be acceptable provided issues in keeping
with the existing property on the street
scene in terms of the style proportion
and materials and it should avoid
significant loss of privacy and Immunity
for Neighbors
at 7.9 of the report the officer
confirms that the extension will be
modest in scale their words and we agree
the extension would be 3.6 meters by
2.55 meters at its widest or 11 feet 9
by 8 feet 4 in old money
it will be subservient to the existing
house in Gable and due to its position
and scale it would not be easily visible
from views outside the site and any
views would be long distance as you've
just heard
the photograph on page 64 does not show
an accurate view from the proposed
extension
however it is welcomed that at 7.23
officers confirmed that there would be
no greater impact on their
design has been based on a review of
extensions in the locality many of which
are two stories
the applicants and Architects have made
it clear throughout the application they
are willing to negotiate with officers
we firmly believe this single story
extension would be in keeping with
existing house and at the same time it
would also enable Simon to make
excuse me would make the to make the
Gable of his home safe we ask you please
to support these planning application
thank you thank you are there any
questions councilor Foster thank you
chair thank you Miss student I love this
over here in case it that's on this
honest it's that one it might be that
one
yeah I think so uh thank you very much
for that
um
right uh when we look at uh what's in
our officers report we've got impact on
Countryside impact on listed building
and impact on uh neighbor immunity and
private sector it's the middle one
impact on listed building and I mention
it because twice now you've mentioned in
keeping with the style proportion and
materials so it's that a statement you
mentioned in keeping the style
proportion of materials can you tell me
why uh when you've mentioned that why
those why those three things style
proportional materials why should they
help us with SDC 6 and stc-12 so it's a
specific question around that I'm not
leading the uh
I'm not leaving Miss stains and but it's
because she's mentioned twice now
keeping with style proportional
materials how it affects that middle
element impact on listed building and
those two policies please so
specifically that yes thank you I
understand the issue that we've had as
speakers is that we've got a planning
application and a list of building
application and in a minute we'll be
doing a speech about the list of
building application so it's been quite
difficult to avoid repetition between
the two so hopefully in the second
speech you will hear more about this
building side of things
um
the application is accompanied by a
planning and Heritage statement
um cons The Architects spent
considerable time looking at the
scale and design and detailing of the
proposals
um you'll hear us talk in a minute about
the roof design in particular which has
been mentioned by the conservation
officer
um
we firmly believe that the extension is
subservient to the existing building it
will apparently it will be absolutely
evident that it is an extension which is
important we're not trying to pretend
that it was part of the original
because it's single story it's on the
end it's set in from both a front-end
rear elevations which you can see on the
floor plans
um we genuinely don't think it has a
significant impact on on the Heritage
asset
I hope that helps thank you
thank you are there any other questions
I'd like to take a seat
are there any questions for the officers
Council faster thank you chair
yeah my question is how this was
originally presented um
uh Adrian and it's it's around when you
said the significant change to size uh
and you said that significant changed
aside it encompassed uh the earlier
extension
and added it to this much more modest
2.55 by 3.6 meter and it's those two you
put together I believe from what you
understood that gave it the um the
definition of significant significant
change to size in in offices views so my
question is uh when that's already been
given uh planning permission and we've
all did should we not look at this
separately when it comes to whether this
is significant or not
okay
and just in terms of that chair the
obviously lc5 talks about extensions to
dwelling houses residential extensions
and it says outside of settlement
development limits proposals which
either individually or cumulatively
involved with significant change in the
scaling character of the original
dwelling will be assessed as a proposal
for a new dwelling so in this instance
officers take into account the extension
to the rear so the two-story rear
extension
the Western elevation and this so a
cumulative impact of that and whether
they
involve it whether they then result in a
significant change in the scale and
character the original dwelling is what
the policy says and if you believe that
it does involve a significant change in
the scaling character that would be
assessed normally as you would for a new
dwelling in the countryside which would
be you wouldn't give permission except
in particular circumstances so that's
the that's the assessment that we have
so
as you've been discussing with with
Charlotte you'll need to take and
viewers to whether as a whole that
the dwelling is is so altered it's going
character in it and also you need to
take into account again as you've been
discussing whether that's an adverse
impact
so it saves that to to Stage process if
you like
any further questions
no
I'll open the floor for debate
councilor Liggett
thank you
um I'm just well I I walk that area as
well so as you said you can't see that
cottage from anywhere
um to be honest with you and also that
little tiny extension my opinion you see
dozens of little tiny extensions on
traditional Derbyshire farm houses
cottages and I think it's in keeping to
be honest I think it'll look rather nice
and like uh Charlotte said
um it won't
it's not trying to be anything it's not
it is obviously a small extension which
as I say I I think you see dozens of
those and I think it just looks in
keeping and items like better than
buttresses
um and I think it obviously it will work
as a fortress
councilman Foster
uh thank you chair
um I'd like to address both impact on
Countryside impact on listed building
and impact on neighbor immunity and
privacy impact on the countryside I
don't think it has an impact at all much
like we just heard from uh Council
Liggett
um it's such a in itself it's such a
it's not modestly small I've been there
and when I've stood alongside that
building I'm surprised that that
gavelen's holding up at all it's not he
can't really see it from the photos but
there's
it's patched up but it's uh it's
surprising that that is actually uh
still holding it up so I don't believe
it's a significant in itself at all on
that side uh you can't certainly can't
see from any neighboring properties uh
so that's the visibility uh on to 7.12
uh the conservation office is concerned
that further extension
um would detract from the character of
the property
um I don't believe it would detract from
the uh property at all so that's a
that's how planning judgments there so
for me I don't think it'd detract from
the character at all
um certainly not having a negative
impact on the character and appearance
of the site at all onto
um the impact on the listed building
which have questioned the witness about
uh on stc-6 and stc-12 stc6 when we look
at how it's described uh it's made of
random Limestone dressed grip Stone
window surround
um slate and painted windows to match so
I think the intention is obviously to
make it match the rest of the the
building there's no there's no I don't
think there'll be any difference at all
when it comes to how it looks compared
to the rest of the building so I think
it ticks that box and on the last one
which I've got to say this this is this
one I find absolutely comical the last
one really is and I know this is the
most funny meeting we've got this
administ version but I'd love to say
impact on neighbor immunity and privacy
on lc5
to set its impacts on any neighbors is
is just it's just it's maddening it
reminds me only of two months ago when
we looked at one in Coal Ashton where we
where we replaced a bungalow and we put
a huge extension on the Bungalow and it
overlooked 12 properties and we had a we
had we had people in here saying this is
going to overlookers and I spoke on that
and that really did impact on uh
neighboring so we shouldn't be talking
about other planning applications but it
really did in the most obvious way and
we let it go through here this one is
the complete opposite on the scale it's
not going to affect anybody at all so
certainly on lc5 is more than acceptable
and stc-12 it isn't contrary to any of
those policies uh a to n yeah
thank you thank you councilor Armitage
signature well I think
uh Council Foster has really said that
if everything that I uh would want to
say I agree entirely with everything
that she said
I used to live opposite that house
and you couldn't see it and the only
thing that gave it away was when he used
to put his Christmas tree up and he used
to light it and that was the only time
you could actually see it so as far as
I'm concerned it you know it it should
be passed
sharing for me just just one point
um just in terms of the the issue on
neighboring Humanity that Council Foster
mentioned just wanted to confirm chair
that officers have concluded that there
wouldn't be an adverse impact on
um privacy and amenity of neighboring
properties just just so the committee
can be clear about that to the bottom of
paragraph 7.23
okay if that's the end of the base I'll
open it for a motion and I'll let the
clock go through the process
all right thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to emotion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if emotion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations then
the member who has moved the motion must
give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving emotion against
office and recommendations should
comprise the relevant planning issues
and be supported by the evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the recommendations or the
different course of action
this will be need to this will need to
be approved by the committee through
another vote
thank you chair
thank you I'll open the floor for a
motion councilor Foster
um yeah thank you chair I'm happy to
propose that we give this uh planning
permission against officers
recommendations uh one is that it
doesn't have an impact on the
countryside so I think that's ss9
are you okay with that Mr okay
yeah that it doesn't uh it doesn't go
against
sdc6 we've already got a description
there
and
another one please
sorry chair
um yeah that it doesn't contravene sdc6
yeah uh that it that it isn't contrary
to anything in SDC 12 a2m
and I think we've already covered uh lc5
chair
is Mr Google map with all the with those
policies there's no problem chair
members of my need to Grant permission
it's only for the minutes I think that
the the reasoning may be necessary but
if members are minded to Grandpa Miss
Cherry and the question that I would ask
is whether any specific conditions that
members would wish us to attach to any
permission granted or whether that
should be and we should be happy that to
be delegated to myself in consultation
with yourself chair and the vice chair
I'm happy with what the character Foster
said yeah I'm just going to Second it
please
okay that's fine we go to the vote yeah
so just to be clear
um that um the recommendation or rather
the motion is to refuse uh officer
recommendations or in other words to
pass the application on the grounds that
it would be in line with policies sc5
ss9 sd6 and SDC 12 and that following
off from uh approval if indeed that's
granted any conditions be delegated to
the planning manager development
Management in consultation with the
German Vice chair that the essence of it
members
councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
councilor Foster
councilor Fennell
councilor Hartzell
or
counselor Lacey
or councilor Liggett or
counselor Jones
councilor Powell
councilor roof
and councilor winley oh
that's ten four and one against the
Motions pasture
thank you now we need this the second
part of the application
just before um a members go on to debate
this I'd just like to remind members of
the particular statutory responsibility
Hub in in terms of
preserving in and taking special regard
to the student building and the planning
issues around it
says we'll go straight into the speakers
again if you'd like to take a seat thank
you
three minutes when you're ready thank
you yes the house is built a random
Limestone we'll also use local random
Limestone to match the existing property
the hole we want to make for access to
the extension is small in comparison to
the overall wall which will be left in
situ most of the area we want to remove
has been poorly repaired during the
renovation and the mortar does not match
the rest of the Gable war or in fact the
spacing of the stones
I'm told the kitchen had several use in
its time and some of the older neighbors
still remember it being used as a pigsty
I managed to buy all photographs and
postcards to show the house from a
distance uh not managed to find anything
closer I do know from talking to those
who've lived around for a long time that
it used to be owned by a Miss Lim and
there was no running water only a
standpipe at the top of the drive
there used to be a fig tree in the
garden brought back by a son of a
previous occupant returning from France
after World War One
they planted the tree and I'm told that
the figs were regularly taken to the
village and handed out unfortunately the
Fig Tree was lost when the house was
renovated but I have bought and planted
another one
I've also managed to trace the original
Stone salting table which was removed
from the property in the 1970s that's my
intention if possible to reincorporate
this into the new kitchen
I do not make anything of the fireplace
in the application because it was not
raised as an issue when I applied before
it's not a nice original fireplace where
there would once have been a stone half
I have an unsightly lump of gray
concrete and where the open fireplace
would once have been we have a crazy
paved stone effect from 2005
I want to reassure you that I will do
all I can to make sure this house is
preserved and looked after for those who
will follow me we would never want to
spoil that which caused us to fall in
love with it
we simply want to make the hose how
suitable for a modern family using the
same Stone from the ground and to ensure
the Gable end is preserved and safe the
extension is small in size and designed
to complement the house and being
keeping with the Gable extension seen on
other houses near us also in random
Limestone some of which are two stories
opposed to our single story plan
wouldn't want to harm a house which just
suffer around 250 years and which we
know we are only the caretakers off
there have been no objections from my
neighbors the window will look onto my
land and this is a house I intend to
live in until old age and the
application for an extension is not for
any commercial gain
I can only ask that you consider
approving my application for what would
be a small kitchen extension but one
which will have a huge positive impact
on me and my family and I'll continue
the enjoyment of living there thank you
thank you are there any questions
nope thank you thank you very much
three minutes when you're ready
thank you as I explained earlier the
design has been amended by a new
architect since the previous scheme a
structural report has been provided and
the application is accompanied by Design
and Heritage statement the officer
report confirms that 7.2 that the ashova
neighborhood plan supports proposals
which preserve our enhanced listed
buildings proposals should use materials
layouts architectural features scale and
design that respond to and do not
detract from the list of building
the extension would be single story and
subservient to Common Bank house the
extension would be crafted by a local
specialist Builder using locally sourced
Limestone to match existing house
we believe the design is in keeping with
both existing house and the local
vernacular a pent roof design was
considered but there are no local
examples the ridge design chosen has
been approved for Gable extensions at
Brookside Cottage to the East and
getting Cottage to the South for example
the roof lights could have been removed
from the design office officers had
requested and they could still be
removed by a condition if cons if the
committee consider them to be harmful we
don't
we firmly believe that this single story
extension would be in keeping with the
existing house and at the same time
would enable Simon to make the Gable of
his home safe
the structural reporters confirm that
the Gable wall requires stabilizing
Works to make it safe this single story
kitchen extension would provide a way of
ensuring the Gable can be made
structurally sound for the future of
this building
an alternative scheme would be
buttressing which we believe would would
be visually harmful and not have the
benefit of improving the accommodation
within the house
your policies allow for extensions to
list the buildings and as you know
extensions have been permitted on many
list of buildings in the ashover area
and Beyond
we ask you please to consider what harm
this kitchen extension would create
the the position of the extension would
follow the linear footprint of the house
unlike the previous proposal it would be
set in from both the front and rear
elevations of the house and would be
constructed in matching materials with
sympathetic detailing
we believe that this modest single story
extension would not harm the character
architectural Merit or historic
interests of the building and would
preserve the significance of this
Heritage asset we ask you please to
support this list of building content
thank you
thank you are there any questions
thank you very much
are there any questions for the officers
I'll open the floor for debate
Council Foster
yeah thank you chair when we look in the
recommendations what is being refused
for uh or the recommendation is uh to
refuse uh it talks about harming the
character the list of building uh as
I've said before I don't believe this
does harm the the character of the
listed building at all
um and you can it's clear from what what
you can see from the building if you if
you saw it that it does need some form
of work it needs buttressing like and
he's taking down and rebuilding so I
don't think this would be uh any harm at
all uh and then lastly in the last
paragraph overall is considered that the
prose Works would fail to preserve the
significance of the Heritage I don't
think that's true I don't think it would
at all so this is a this is a matter of
uh you know it's our planning judgment
yeah as a committee uh and I believe we
should be giving this planning
permission thank you chair thank you any
other comment
Council Armitage
thank you chair uh I agree with that
everything that uh Council Apostle has
said again and uh
as far as I'm concerned it's a way of
preserving this list of building because
uh it's like the engineer has said that
if something isn't done it's going to
fall down and that seems to be the best
and sympathetic way of preserving this
building
thank you
Adrian do you want to say anything
before we move to a vote or mostly
all I would like to say chairs to note
the comments of your conservation
officer at paragraph 4.4 and it's not
just the issue about the extension
before you this afternoon it's the
cumulative impact of
extensions to three sides of the listed
building and the gradual deterioration
of the significance of the Heritage
asset that is of concern to officers and
the lack of a justification in this
instance to demonstrate why the
extension is
required and also to
justify the public benefits that
outweigh the harm that's identified by
officers the the benefits are all to the
um owner of the building so there is no
public benefit that in the officer's
opinion outweighs that but I would ask
members chair to
be aware of and appreciate the comments
of the conservation officer in this
instance and the concern that officers
have about that gradual dilution of the
building's character and significance
and also remind members that you should
have particular regard to the
desirability preserving the building or
its setting and that's a statue of
responsibility that you must discharge
chair thank you
thank you councilor Armitage yeah I'd
just like to point out the fact that the
uh officer uh when they went to the
house and they were actually went inside
if they're gone inside they would have
seen all the visible cracks
and I think it was very remiss of
somebody who is supposed to be a
Heritage officer never bothered going
inside and I am quite sure that the
majority of uh
Heritage officers when they're dealing
with listed buildings one of the
criteria which they should use is to go
inside and the officer never did
thank you any other comment and you'd
like to councilor Foster
yeah when we're talking about uh I'll be
making a proposal uh when you move into
that part of the meeting but while we're
talking about actual policy in this part
of the application we're talking about
sdc6 and the three elements that their
proposals for alterations two are
changes of use of a list of building
will be supported where they preserve
the significance of the Heritage I
believe it does preserve uh the
significance of this Heritage asset so
that's the first one proposals should
use materials layout architectural
features skill and design that respond
to and do not be tracked from Real
Estate building I think that's the case
too we are they are using the materials
there and three proposals which allow
for viable uses that are compatible with
the conservation of the fabric of the
building people are living there so stc6
I'm absolutely fine with that
yeah
any further comments
no we all moved
uh the motion
thank you
does anyone want to put motion on the
table
counselor Foster
um yes chair thank you for that uh I
think we should give this planning
permission uh and as I've said just
before just just less time sport based
on stc6
I think that's the only policy there
that's applicable in this case yeah it's
just on its dc6 thank you thank you I'd
like to say on that
just before you go to the vote chair
again if the committee is minded to to
Grant Mercy building consent are members
happy for that to be decision delegated
to myself in terms of the conditions and
again consultation with yourself and the
vice chair chance uh just clarification
thank you
so just to be clear then sure it's to
approve the application contrary to
offer recommendations uh the essential
reasons being that it is in line with uh
policy SD C6 uh and that any
um conditions be delegated to the
planning manager development Management
in consultation with the chair and vice
chair
okay
councilor Armitage
counselor Cooper
councilor Foster
counselor for now
councilor Hartson or
counselor Lacey
councilor Liggett oh
councilor Jones four
councilor Powell
counselor roof
and councilor winley
oh
well that's only one against members of
the motion has passed thank you thank
you very much
all right moving on to our final
application for this afternoon
which is reference number 22 forward
slash zero one zero zero four four slash
FL
and this is for
little handling
over to the problem officer
thank you chair
again Cheryl for members to the late
conference report of yesterday in this
case chair the applicant seeks consent
to form a new era of car parking access
from the Pub's existing car park at
middle Handley and to relocate a stable
building the site is located in the
green belt while certain development
including changes of use and Engineering
operations may not be an appropriate
developed in Greenbelt due to the
associate the associated activity
proposed here in connection with car
parking and general comings and goings
officers consider that the car parking
area would be inappropriate in Greenbelt
that the Stables relocation would add
harm to Greenbelt openness officers
concerns are increased due to the
acoustic fencing that environmental
health officers consider necessary to
mitigate the impact of the car parking
on Residential Properties nearby overall
chair officers do not consider there are
any very special circumstances that
outweigh this harm to Greenbelt openness
and so recommend that the application is
refused
just in terms of some reprise of what we
looked at yesterday chair the
application site
in order to be able to see and Westfield
Lane as it runs through middle Handley
here the Devonshire arms existing pub
with its car park to join you with an
existing access and access to the site
will be taken from the existing car park
into the new although an existing access
would be retained for use by forces and
other Associated accesses and to the
site from Westfield Lane
so the application site share outlined
in red members will be able to see the
existing access from Westfield Lane here
which would be retained and new access
would be formed this point here to the
new site
stable building on the site will be
really relocated to a position at the
northeast of the site
that's a close-up of that chair and then
in terms of detailing
members will hopefully be able to see
here that the existing Car Park area
here access through the
boundary to access the new car parking
area which is here
with two lines of Parker car parking
with a central aisle stable building
relocated to the northeast of the site
that's the stable building just for
clarity it would be relocation of the
existing building
and just share a couple of photographs
of the site the site
is this area here you can see the stable
building here Westfield Lane in the
foreground the existing access which
would be retained this point here
shallow access to the car park is
designed to go from the existing
facility
and just looking from the top of where
that access Drive is across the site
site
in front of you here this is a stable
building that will be relocated the
acoustic fencing would be to mitigate
the impact of the car park on
neighboring properties which lie to the
east or primarily to the east
thank you chair
thank you and I do believe we have one
speaker
um James Stannard
you you'd like to confirm your name and
have three minutes
chronic Services I'm the agent thank you
the Devonshire arms Public House and BNB
lies at the heart of middle Hanley is
the focal point of the village that
makes a positive contribution to
community being a popular venue for
locals and tourists alike providing
employment opportunities and wider
economic benefits for the region like
all Hospitality businesses the
Devonshire arms suffered badly during
covet and has not still not recovered it
is imperative that the council encourage
and support the ongoing recovery of this
important rural business and its
long-term sustainability the highways
Authority agree with our submission that
the 19 car parking space is our
substandard for the scale of the
business which has a capacity of 100
diners seven double bedrooms and employs
15 part-time and 15 full-time staff in
the absence of any adoptive parking
standards we submit that as a bare
minimum of 37 spaces are required in
this isolated rural location although it
is reasonable to argue that the more
appropriate number is actually far
higher there can be no question that the
current car park is still small by
modern standards a busy times during the
summer months pensions are repeatedly
forced to park on the Villages of
Westfield Lane when the car park is full
which I'm informed happens every week
seriously threatening the highway safety
of both roads users and pedestrians
there are therefore two clear reasons
which justify the proposed developments
and making it an absolute necessity
number one the increase in parking
spaces will maximize the number of
patrons visiting the pub at any one time
adding its recovery from covid so the
benefits of the local community in wider
rural economy this is a clear public
benefit that should be giving
significant weight in the overall
planning balance two the increase in
parking will also prevent chaotic and
dangerous parking from taking place on
Westfield Lane thereby reducing the
serious risk of a fatal accident and
enhancing the highway safety of Road
users and pedestrians which is welcomed
by the highway Authority this is also a
clear public benefit they should be
given significant weight in the overall
planning balance offices have not cited
a reason for refusal regarding the
potential impacts on the members of the
public or residential immunity there
report fails to take into consideration
the careful choice of a grass-like
surface as opposed to a hard tarmac
which mitigates any landscape and visual
impacts the report contends that it is
General activity and use of the car park
which would harm the openness of the
green belts we're saying that dudes the
site being contained by a strong
boundary treatment not visible from any
nearby public footpaths and that the
busyness of the car park would vary
depending on the time of year that the
openness of the green belt will be
preserved however in any event if
members were to reach a different
conclusion we strongly urge you to
consider that the two very clear and
justifiable reasons for the proposal are
significant public benefits that do
amount to very special services and
outweigh any harm to landscape character
in the green belts and we therefore ask
you to approve the application thank you
thank you to councilor Foster
uh yeah thank you for that this this to
me looks fairly this
the very special circumstances were set
out two two main reasons um obviously
with three minutes I had I wanted to
speak for a lot longer but I can't so we
tried to yeah so the two I'll go for
them again two very clear very special
circumstances number one it's basically
socio-economic benefits
arising from the pub recovery from
covid-19 and making sure that there is
provision for parking so that the the
maximum capacity of that Pub can be
can be um can be done at the same time
without people are people are my my
client advises with the people are not
coming to the pub because there is
completely insufficient parking and they
are minded to go somewhere else that's
that's one of the main reasons so it's
to encourage that long-term
sustainability and make sure that there
is parking for staff for people using
the BNB for people eating there if you
think about how many people yeah so the
second one is all about highway safety
and it's about the highway Authority
welcoming the fact that we are creating
as a sufficient amount of off street
parking that makes the fact that they
will no longer be parking on the highway
they are parking on grass 30s which is
part of it is going to be subject to a
traffic regulation order so double
yellow lines are going to come on to
part of part of that lane and that will
even that will make it so that people
have to go even further out park on the
bus there's a brow of the hill just just
a bit for further down so that and
there's a bus stop bang opposite the pub
car park so the fact that the highway
authorities supports this application
they welcome it that is a clear public
benefit because it's it supports the
safety of pedestrians and Highway users
so they're your two very special
circumstances that would think outweigh
the harm
thank you any other Council household
yeah I heard your uh numbers I heard you
said there was a hundred diners uh and
how many rooms was it that you've got
and staff seven double bedrooms 15
full-time staff and 15 part-time staff
on a router basis
so part of the part of the parking
provision is if you think about
changeover when all of those staff and
all of those occupants are going to be
on site at any one time there is no
nothing left or a sufficient amount
you've got just to break that hundred
down it's 16 side and 40 outside so
imagine in height for summer holidays
that's what we're getting at it is a
significant chronic on the provision
okay
any other questions
no thank you if you'd like to take a
seat thank you Jim I just um raised one
point before we go into other questions
please it's just in terms of this this
impact on neighbors and the point that
Mr stanard made um and officers deal
with that at um
paragraph
6.11 in terms of the the issue about the
impact on neighbors and environmental
health officers requesting that if the
wish was granted they would want an
acoustic fence officers haven't put that
as one term of refusal because
um it could be dealt with by condition
but if members are minded to refuse the
application and they are concerned about
the issue of impact on neighbors and
that could also it could be added as a
reason for refusal though quite how that
we would I don't know as there is a
a way of conditioning that out if
members reminded to Grant permission but
that's the reason why that's not in
particular a reason for refusal in its
own right chair so I just wanted to make
that point of clarity and hope that
helps members understand that particular
point
thank you are there any uh further
questions the officers
no thank you I'll open the floor for
debate
that's the answer
uh yeah um
to be honest looking at it I think the
the benefits of this for the uh for the
damage your arms and for the local
economy you know providing 15 jobs 15 14
15 part-time jobs
um I'll demanded to accept this to help
development to that area
any other comment councilor Foster yeah
it's for me this is open and short but
it'll get any clearer than this at least
one I've seen in a long time
we've got all our policies in front of
us ss10
and we've also got the national planning
framework and it's clearly and it's
accepted that it's already inappropriate
development I think officers agree on
that it's certainly an appropriate
development and the only way we can give
this permission is if we've got those
very special circumstances which is like
what Richard wanted what I asked of the
the applicants uh advisor
and socio-economic benefits
to the pub
and to the workers uh like you've said
our special circumstances they don't
come as a very special circumstances
they just don't
um and when it comes to highway safety
as well you know we've got to be very
careful when we look at anything like
that people part where they Park and uh
and as for what we what what we hear
from DCC and highways I take very little
notice of uh there's a lot of a lot of
them do here so certainly those two
things aren't they're just not very
special circumstances it's simple as
that there's not much more to say
said chair the the assessment that
planning committee need to make
this afternoon in respect to a green
belt is first of all is the development
in appropriate development or not
inappropriate adopt if I can use that
that term now to be
not inappropriate it needs to meet one
of the exceptions to Greenbelt policy
and as officers have set out in the
report
changes of use of land and Engineering
operations may be not inappropriate I.E
appropriate developed in the green belt
providing they preserve openness that's
the test now in terms of advice that
government have government have set out
in their advice document that
um companies and goings of traffic and
issues surrounding that can have an
impact on openness and that's the stance
that officers have taken in this
instance that the large area have cut
the area of car parking that's proposed
in officers opinion
not so much by the
works that are proposed they're very
limited at ground level but in terms of
the above ground development the comings
and goings of vehicles the communities
are going to people the activity
surrounding that officers are very much
of the view that that is
impacting on openness and that is a
significant impact on openness where
there isn't currently any development so
that's the stance that officers have
taken and members will need to make a
decision whether they agree or not with
that if members do agree with officers
then the next step needs to be whether
any very special circumstances that
outweigh that impact of harm because
government have said the protection of
Greenbelt is a prime importance
and in terms of that an assessment of
harm needs to be undertaken first of all
and officers take the view that the harm
is significant because there isn't any
development there at the moment the area
of land that would be taken up by this
activity is significant and therefore
the level of harm is in its own right a
great weight so then you need to
consider whether there's very any very
special circumstances in that way that
is counselor Foster has discussed that
again needs to be a discussion and a
consideration that you have and you need
to balance that against the harm
if you follow all that through and
that's your your conclusion in the view
of officers that leads to a significant
harm to Greenwell to openness
inappropriate development and officers
are very much of the opinion that very
special circumstances aren't
outweighing that harm in this case so
hopefully that provides members with
process that we've gone through and that
you need to go through to arrive at your
conclusion and that I I believe it sets
out quite clearly in the report and
you've heard what Mr Sanada has said
that that is your your judgment but you
need to follow that assessment to do a
green belt harm
thank you any other comment Council
Buster yeah uh yeah I thought we'd
already made the assessment that it was
inappropriate but if you have to make
that
okay we now come to putting emotion on
the table
and I'd like to recommend that we go
with the office's recommendations to
refuse the application thank you
you'd like to uh clarify all right chair
so the motion is to approve officer
recommendations
answer Armitage
counselor Cooper
councilor Foster
counselor for now
councilor Hartzell
against
councilor Lacey
okay
councilor Lucas
councilor Jones
against
councilor Powell
counselor roof
and councilor winley
so I make that H4 the motion and three
against the motion as pasture
thank you thank you very much
nearly there
vitamin Levin planning appeals I'll Now
put on the planning officers to explain
our next report
sorry
not quite joke
we've had the three appeals dismissed
this this month chat I always say this
to members and they do take some reading
and they do help and assist us and the
counseling decision makers to set out
the reasoning in all the cases why
decisions are taken in particular I
would
suggest to members that you read the
leverton UK limited appeal it's a
it's a green belt appeal and it does go
into some detail about the issues we've
just been discussing about spatial and
visual impact on on openness in
appropriate development Etc so
um in my opinion it's it's well written
it does go through the process very well
I probably didn't explain it quite as
well as the inspector set it out but
again I would recommend that in
particular chair that that decision is
one that you read
thank you any questions
yeah absolutely absolutely brilliant
but there's no other questions I'm going
to bring the meeting to a close but
before I do that I'd like to thank our
planning officers and team our
governance team for all their support
over the last four years and also all
the members here today thank you for all
your support over the last four years
and I do know that there will be some of
you that haven't
taken up the challenge to restart and I
can actually understand that but I wish
you all the very best for the future
thank you